[Music]
the first time I saw images of flying
cars I have to say I was skeptical such
pictures are all over the Internet
some of them seem to actually exist but
none of the companies I contacted wish
to talk to me it was top secret they
said or they didn't have time or they
weren't far enough along and so on only
one startup in the Netherlands called
Paul VI's said come on over we can show
you something
listen model this is a model of what the
final product would look like here you
see it all folded up and that's the way
it'll be on the road these here are the
rotary blades they'll have a mast in the
middle and the tail unit has inserted
back here light back and so this is how
it'll drive on the road it'll have a
total length of four meters and a width
of two meters so it's a very compact
vehicle that fits into any parking
structures vehicle medium is a Anita's
Paco's Falcon a prototype was already
driven and flown during a test run five
years ago but a concrete runway and
pilot's license are required for the
flying car to take off
and I get the impression that handling a
car like this is not as easy as you
might think the year this is your
accelerator for flight mode you push it
up and that gives you more power
whereas in driving mode you regulate the
speed with a conventional accelerator
pedal and you also have a classic
steering wheel for driving in flight
mode you steer with a joystick a Yank
nipple the prototype is no longer
registered maintaining a permanent
operating license is very expensive but
the final product finished and fully
registered is due to hit the market next
year the company has been working on it
for nearly 20 years the team has grown
to 40 international engineers located
just outside Amsterdam combining the
functions of a car and an aircraft is no
easy task
it's very new very exciting very
challenging lots of challenges every day
that's what an engineer are lost and
lots of challenges what is difficult is
wait so keeping the weight down because
you have this dual functionality driving
and flying so keeping the weight down is
very difficult and the other thing is
the legislation so the driving on the
road flying in the air you have to set
of rules and those rules they sometimes
bite each other so you so to manage both
at the same time is very difficult
the engineers spent years trying to
modify a car engine to also function as
the engine of an aircraft normally the
two are incompatible investors have kept
pumping millions into the startup even
though setbacks have occurred on a
regular basis we thought it was much
easier before that would be more like
engineering less invention but to be
concluded after years of work that it's
definitely a combination of inventions
and a lot of hard work but this more
difficult than we expected
yeah
[Music]
now finally the PAL V Liberty is said to
be almost finished the driving part of
the flying car is already complete it's
an odd looking vehicle that leans into
curves like a motorcycle you can travel
up to 180 kilometres an hour and the
cockpit is also furnished both parts now
need to be put together I had a slightly
queasy feeling as we started down the
runway in the flying part I'm afraid of
heights
the propeller started up and in just a
few meters we were airborne
so this is what it feels like when a
flying car takes off heading straight
for our destination and leaving roads
and traffic jams behind
now that the flying car will soon be on
the market potential customers are
calling almost daily and requesting test
flights there are even some pre-orders
although the pile V Liberty will cost a
hefty five hundred thousand euros we
recently had a press release in our
YouTube video has got over five million
clicks so far that means people are
interested in flying cars s and fleeting
an auto swish deed maybe it's not such a
crazy idea after all flying cars soaring
above congested roads when the pal V
Liberty goes on sale next year we'll
find out if it really is ready for
takeoff
you